emerging in Inverness steeped in another
crisis fresh political and personal pain
for a first Minister after his ally
friend and predecessor Nicholas
sturgeon's arrest I won't be suspending
Nicholas and I'll be treating her
exactly the same way as I treated for
example column bitty both released
without charge and therefore there's no
reason for me to suspend them I have
great confidence in the future of my
party in an explosive development Nicola
sturgeon faced seven hours of detention
by police examining the smp's finances
and funding released without charge
pending further inquiries she insisted
she was innocent of wrongdoing but some
within the party believed she should
step aside
I should consider whether it might be
over the last few weeks for her to
resign her party membership uh
voluntarily just temporarily
[Applause]
this has been the toughest time the SMP
has suffered these the images of the
raid on Nicholas sturgeon's home in
April the same day her husband Peter
Morrow was detained and released without
charge
they're political opponents attempting
to capitalize and canvas support I'm
more interested in what it means for The
Wider country and what it means for how
they operate in government this is a
political party that is famed now for a
culture of secrecy and cover-up in
government and that has had devastating
consequences it's now an incompetent and
dysfunctional SNP government and that's
why we need fundamental change
it's quite frankly the case that
Nicholas sturgeon with a suspended
Nicola sturgeon because when she was
leader of the SMP and SMP politicians
were arrested and questioned by the
police she either removed the party Whip
or she suspended them there are some
within the SMP who fear this police
probe regardless of the outcome risks
causing major electoral damage and they
now want some distance with their former
leader and as police continue to examine
what Nicholas sturgeon said under
caution in that interview will she now
be feeling that she is becoming a
distraction to the party that she's
fought for her entire political career
as the police continue their inquiries
the political heat is Extreme once again
where the stakes could not be higher
Conor Gillis Sky News Glasgow